that's sad
I was really upbeat for a moment now I'm
sad
the approval numbers dive for the prez
who's barely alive
yeah his favorability is down to a third
while in his pants
you a trendlined average by savix I love
their tiny car what is this Joe Biden's
approval is now just 35 percent
his voters must be turning over in their
graves
[Applause]
[Music]
Drew Biden's numbers are crashing like
Nancy Pelosi's husband
red meat
glowed but the country's doing horribly
and I live here
Biden's only above water in Hawaii
Massachusetts and Vermont and yes Emily
those are still States
even in Delaware his approval rating is
36 percent
meanwhile according to NBC News Biden is
reportedly frustrated with his own staff
and feels like he can't catch a break
quote he makes a clear and succinct
statement only to have AIDS rushed to
explain that he actually meant something
else the so-called cleanup campaign he's
told advisors undermines him
well sounds like maybe it's time for Joe
to name names if he could remember names
oh this is gas prices hit a record high
over the Memorial Day Weekend according
to AAA whatever that is it's approaching
an average of five bucks and when Trump
was President it was a buck 77 per
gallon
which means
you the Applause
which means by the end of Joe's term gas
will be 800 a gallon
just kidding no way he makes it to the
end of his term
he's gonna retire early he's retiring
early this is my prediction so he's sad
that he can't catch a break what about
us the country makes the Hunger Games
look like a romantic comedy
Joe what say you
hey look look look the gas prices are
not that high all right you just
you can't trust those guys at AAA
they're all alcoholics that's how they
get in that group come on and uh
yeah I'm clear and succinct that's what
Joe is I'm CL I've always been succinct
you know the difference between
succinct and success
Inked and S just those two sounds
so put that in your pipe and it's stick
your wad in it yes
Jamie
foreign
you get politics in Alaska right it's
delivered there yeah where you live they
have all you guys have politics you have
like politicians we just started getting
politics and we just got Miss Pac-Man oh
yeah
delay is it
flame Biden for everything
I mean not everything but my like it
seems to be a trend yes you know did it
not stick out to anybody when he said
like oh I say this clear and succinct
statement and then the aides try to
clarify I don't when I think Biden I
don't think clear is succinct I think
unclear and he stinks
and I think eventually uh these approval
ratings are as ridiculous I think
eventually they'll just have the
approval ratings it'll just be a list of
the people that do
I'm like oh Jim
SO gas is gas is crazy right and in
Alaska we actually it's it's it's
probably I think it's 550. I started
ubering I don't have anybody around here
does that but it I usually save money by
ubering as opposed to guess and no joke
uh we just got Uber in Fairbanks Alaska
a couple months ago and true story the
first time the first three times I
called Uber the same guy came
I swear to God it was this guy Matt and
he goes just came here it was one guy he
said he was making like all this money
because no one had like caught on that
you could drive Ubers the same yeah and
then oddly enough because this is what
kind of place in Alaska is I'm a single
guy you know I'm getting worse none of
this is jokes I went on Tinder there's
one person on Twitter
and it
and it's that guy who drives the Uber
you know in Alaska if you go to grinder
there'll be a lot of bears
my people are shocked by that joke it's
like that's actually a fact it is not
that I would know this cat but I guess
there's an upside to all this inflation
I suppose right
no no
I don't think there's an upside I think
it's awful I also I I have a hard time
not feeling kind of bad for Biden though
yeah because you know like he's never
been a guy that people really took
seriously and I kind of know how that
feels yeah
um
unfortunately
but I feel like once you make it to be
the president of the United States of
America you think that people might
start taking you seriously and they
still don't so it's probably never going
to happen yeah um he doesn't seem like
he wants to be doing this and I can't
blame him because there's no way I live
to be that old but I just don't I it's
hard to not feel bad for my if it didn't
impact me and all of us so much because
it seems to keep getting worse that is
true that is true you know Buck uh the
lady who claims I don't take her
seriously I can't remember her name
the problem with the problem the problem
with the problem is that it affects
everyone like if it was just small
things but inflation hits everybody and
he cannot pretend that somehow that this
is like okay or normal yeah speaking of
of small things big things when Trump
said that he wanted two scoops of ice
cream it was like a huge issue with the
White House remember this where he got
two scoops everyone got one right and
then there was all the oh but is that an
official policy they actually reported
all right stuff so some of the cleanup
on Isle Biden is stuff like I mean yeah
we'll nuke China if they go after Taiwan
that's a big deal you know that's a big
problem like I can't say that stuff when
you're the commander-in-chief on a
highly sensitive political issue so the
fact that now he's walking around saying
who's correcting me it's kind of like
everybody's correcting it exactly
because they don't all want to die yes
and that's an incentive
now
but Emily says he wants to speak for
himself should he I mean let him once
he's left that position because to your
point we're either left with just what
he said and that makes us either
confused or dead or will accept the
cleanup because at least then we can
sort of continue operating as a nation
cat please don't feel sorry for him
that's like when a serial killer gets
finally arrested and prosecuted like 60
decades later or 60 years later and
everyone's like no he's an old man now
do not feel sorry but do you think
people would take me more seriously if I
started going by Catherine cymph yes yes
they would my dear no I think it should
be I should flip it so it's Catherine
Tim so it's C period so you part your
name on the left oh yes right yes
indubitably I do have more initials so
you do yeah think about that after work
go somewhere
admit it
submit it totally ignored you're a very
good question or you're a very good
point that like somehow we bequeath
Mercy to Old bad people right I said
because age just age makes every inmate
look fatherly yes all the hair goes
right all right hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else